buddy hi everyone thank you for being
here
so this is session 14
of itcs 2022.
um as the tradition of itcs
the assistant chair will give
i'm going to give a very short like
brief overview of the talks of this
session so we have five talks i want to
give every speaker 10 minutes
okay so i'm just going to take like a
few minutes of your time
to give some overview and and make sure
everybody is intrigued for the session
and it stays to the end
okay
and so uh
let me close this okay
so usually there's this search of a
unifying thing for the for the session
sometimes it's quite hard because the
papers are different so here i'm going
to something broad okay about all these
papers are about doing the impossible
okay and of course they're not actually
done by the impossible but you know as i
read them this is what i feel and i can
show off the paper more than the authors
themselves
okay so this is what i'm gonna do so the
first stock
uh so this is on the download rate of
homework secret sharing and
like in one sentence what they do
is they're gonna do secret sharing with
less than one bit
okay so that's really doing the
impossible
and how do they do that well okay it's
not really less than one bit there's
some amortized thing of the download
break
but really first time you read the paper
like oh no you cannot do better and then
they're like oh you actually can you do
better
when you amortize things and so this is
really a paper about you think you know
everybody everything about um
shamir secret sharing and
you know every day it's it's quite
amazing that we can still get more out
of this
um the
second
the second paper in this session is
small box cryptography
so what they do is the in this paper
they're considered consider the aes
encryption scheme
and they prove that it is secure
okay so this is completely impossible
uh of course at least without like
pulling that piece of an np
but really
reading the paper you just get the
feeling that it's almost there okay they
have a very nice proof of how they start
to break
this
aes box to small and small parts and
they get to something they call the the
small box
and uh and it's very very nice it's like
really almost a poof of vegas
the tail talk is on advocate hardness of
np
and
this is like you know in the rent of the
theory this is like a one of the most
interesting uh
open problems right so how do we get
from the worst case hardness of the of
np to an average case hardness of np
actually amnon touchman has a very nice
paper showing that
if p is different than np okay then
where are these hard instances you can
actually find them
okay they're not actually too hard to
find so you can sample them but the
running time of this distribution is is
not polynomial it's only quasi
polynomial and this is really not what
we want we want like a real polynomial
time distribution you know that fools
any a higher polynomial of the cells
um so this is one step in that direction
okay of course they don't completely
resolve this question but it's really a
nice step and
i don't know all these steps really make
me optimistic that me we might solve
this question in
the next
10 or 100 years
um
okay the next paper is well the title
itself is already something that's
impossible to do so that they're beating
the classical impossibility
uh and the
opposition verification i would say
they're breaking the speed of light
okay so i want to know that somebody is
near me
so i'm going to tell him okay just i'll
send him a ping and he has to respond
and i can time this and i know that if
you know by the speed of light if he
answers very quickly i know that he has
to be nearby
and then you can do many of these things
um but
it's quite amazing what
approvals can fool you okay in this
setting and here they gave they give a
very nice solution
uh with quantum portals
um and uh okay so stay tuned for that i
think this is a very cool paper
and the last uh paper so this is on io
and this indistinguishability of
foscation
um but the thing they're doing that is
possible is really
using zero circuits
okay to beat quantum adversaries so why
of zero circuit so powerful this is like
a circuit that always outputs zero okay
this is like the useless thing in
history and uh this really helps okay of
course this is a obfuscation of zero
circuits
um but this is very tight so actually
they do two impossible things they build
io and then they show how from this io
that they build it's actually very
powerful
um yeah so i really also like this paper
so i think we have a very great session
and with that let's see what's the time
yeah with that we'll start um with our
first
speaker
so
uh
so this is going to be victor right okay
great all right
[Music]
yeah we can hear you victor the stage is
yields please introduce the the
co-authors
yeah hi guys i'm victor kolob well
thanks for having me
uh this is a gentle open ingredient
firstly you value shy and mellywood
and today i'll talk to you about the
download rate for morphe signaturing
so
consider the following
application of fhe alice has some input
and she wants to delegate the
computation of some function on that
input
such that then bob can recover
the evaluation of the function on the
input
so what fha gives us first
it allows us
the scheme to be such that the server
cannot learn
input
and also the work bob needs to do to
recover the value can be significantly
smaller and the complete then the
complexity of the function being
evaluated
now a homophobic signal sharing of hss
for short can be viewed as a distributed
variant of fhe where instead of
encryption
we are doing the secret sharing and here
d privacy
in this stop just means that any
collusion of this servants or less
cannot recover the secret input
now uh
the downside of hss compared to fha is
that we need to assume that there are
multiple non-colluded servers but for
many applications this is not an issue
and on the flip side we can get various
efficiency features such as editable
construction and we don't need to worry
about keys and also unlike an encryption
scheme uh signaturing and hss can exist
with information theoretic security for
example for simple functions
so why
are computations on signature data
useful so
one scenario could be that the clients
have some input
and they want to learn some statistical
information which depends on all of the
inputs collectively
another application is private
information retrieval which is a
well-known primitive
where the client wants to recover in a
private manner some record from a
database
from
from the database which is replicated
between
some servers
and indeed in both of these applications
and in many others
we care about large-scale computations
on signature inputs so here the large
scale means either the record size is
large
or
in the first example there are many
statistical functions we want to compute
so the primary goal of this work is to
try to minimize the download cost for
the client
so looking for
for edges for degrading polynomials
how can we construct such schemes for
example we can use shamir's secret
sharing
and indeed
in this case the download rate for the
client
is one over the number of servers well
download rate just means that
the amount of information we want
divided by the amount the total amount
of information we download
is the download rate
now can we do better than one over the
number of servers the answer is yes we
can use the so-called picture mirror
where instead of
encoding in chamier one secret value we
encode the
more than one secret value
but then the download rate for degree
polynomials approaches one over d as the
number of servers grows
and this begs the question can we
approach rate one in some manner
so in this work
one way uh we show how to solve it is to
use the so-called universality of cnn
secret sharing which was introduced by
cameron dunganshine from 2005
and
the approach to do it is to first start
from some key private cnn sharing of the
inputs
then it is not difficult to see that
this can be converted to a td
a private senate sharing of the outputs
where the outputs are just the
polynomial evaluations of the secret
inputs
and using the universality of cmf we can
convert the same sharing to any linear
secret sharing in particular we can
consider a joint linear signal sharing
with high rate
and this gives us our hss scheme
but then the downside of this simple
approach is that the upload cost has a
term which goes like like the number of
servers choose the security the security
threshold
but
what comes to the rescue is the
regenerating red solomon poles
and we cannot use off-the-shelf
regenerative elite element codes but we
can adapt ideas from this literature
and
this gives us a scheme uh with shamir
secret sharing a
input shells instead of a cnf
input shells and then this term becomes
just roughly the number of servers minus
the security threshold moving on to our
results in the first powerful first part
of our result we obtain an optimal
download linear edges
for low degree polynomials here linear
just means that both the sharing
reconstruction algorithms are linear
functions
and optimal download means
[Music]
that we obtain both a positive and
negative result so indeed for t private
k server h says for degree d polynomials
we obtain rate
1 minus dt over k and
one application of this is for
information theoretic t private case of
bir for enter size databases
with polynomial
upload cost and download rate which is
as you can see in the slide
and this can be compared to the optimal
rate for bir without upload cost
restriction uh which is one minus t over
k divided by y minus two of k to the
power of n
and even for small database sizes this
optimal download rate is roughly one
minus t over k so we
sort of reach the optimal
we approach the optimal download rate a
second part of our result is a black box
rate amplification technique for hss
with additive construction
in this talk
i won't show you the
black box rate amplification techniques
themselves
but i'll just i can just give you some
corollaries that we can obtain from
this approach
so for example we can obtain a t private
k-server hss for circuits from lwe
with a high download rate
we can also obtain a one private case
level pir from the minimal cryptographic
assumption of one-way functions
of course with a
upload cost
and this is compared to previous high
rate kr constructions from lwe or ddh
where
on the flip side
they have
one they require only one server but
there the record length l needs to go
like a polynomial invisibility parameter
while our result gives a sort of a
different flavor because
the record length can just be the number
of servers minus one
and it is independent of the security
parameter
uh furthermore we can obtain one private
k server hss for budget programs from
ddh of dcr
with high rate
and going back to information theoretic
security we can obtain uh a piya scheme
with subpolynomial upload cost and rate
which approaches one as the number of
servers goes to infinity
now finally in the first part of our
results we obtain a non-linear rate
amplification
technique for hss
so what unifies the previous two types
of results is that we need to increase
the number of servers to increase the
download rate and this begs the question
can we somehow increase the download
rate without increasing the number of
servers
so the main observation here is that the
output shafts are non-uniform and
correlated so we can draw inspiration
from distributed source coding
unfortunately the
well-known slapping wolf
coding result does not apply here
syntactically because of
the privacy requirement of hss the
servers don't know the distribution
nevertheless we are able to obtain a
slapping worth style result for exercise
with non-linear reconstruction
and the negligible error probability and
applying it to a one private three
server hss for the end of two bits were
able to beat the one-third
rate
and this hss can be useful for example
for
applications such as private settings
so this is all and thank you
okay thank you very victim thank you
very much
er we do have a minute from question so
if there's any question from the
audience or colonists
you can raise your hand
um
okay
yeah you can also just admit yourself if
you have a question
okay so we're just gonna move to the
next talk
um
so this is small box cryptography
you're giving the talk
um yes i am okay so you can show your
screen
um
sure
um you're able to see my screen right
yes this is great
perfect thank you uh thanks for the
introduction uh
uh this is the talk about small box
cryptography this is joint work with
evgeny jarvis over at nyu and daniel
vicks had northeastern university and
entity research
sorry um
so
the question that we begin with is what
is the biggest open problem in
cryptography now obviously there's no
one right answer but a possible
candidate which is also the motivating
application for our research is the
provable security of aes and the reason
being
it's quite it's used everywhere and
every day
now with that being said what is a yes
and if you actually take a minute to
write it down it looks a bit messy it
looks like a chicken scribble meets a
doctor's note
uh but we love theater editions love a
good abstraction and we have done just
that and we have sort of taken the
essence of aes and abstracted it out to
something known as a substitution
permutation network
so an spn essentially is a sequence of
structured drums
um
where you have uh you can see the figure
over here where you basically have these
three operations a key addition a
substitution and a permutation
um and the point here is that the s box
is the only non-linear piece here and
why is it interesting is also because a
lot of other ciphers have also gone on
to use the same design um
so considering how heavily it is used
and how heavily it has inspired a whole
series of cyphers the question we ask
now is can we prove security
uh and the thing is we cannot prove it
unconditionally at least not without
proving p versus np and taking home a
billion dollars
and there are some results however which
are interesting but in a very restricted
type of attacks
uh in this work we ask is can we be a
little more ambitious can we prove it
from uh either using an idealized model
or some assumption
but then we hit a roadblock and the
reason is that this s-box by design is
very small because you want the process
to be efficient and so on and it is the
only source of hardness
now
um and so it's unclear how to exactly do
it but sort of this this box uh
and combining this s box which is small
with an idealized model or an assumption
and recall that also an spn is a
structure is a series of structured
grounds and there is not a lot of theory
on how to iterate something so small
such as an spf for many rounds and get
to get reasonable result at least at
least not until this work
so
this is a setting now let me sell our
remedy or tool and we call this small
box cryptography
it is a mixture of proofs and hardness
conjectures
and the former is liked by us
theoreticians and the latter seems to be
necessary unless once again we solve p
vs np um and it basically consists of
three steps the framework and it could
be applied to a lot of things we do it
for an spn uh aes setting and we also do
it for a prg or a stream cipher and
there are three uh
the first step is basically a
traditional reduced run proof where we
prove it either for one run or in the
case of an sp and we do it for three
rounds the second step is sort of this
hardness amplification and this could
possibly be provable and in the case of
sp and it is provable if we know the key
schedule
the third step which is the
the conjecture part is the big to small
conjecture and the way to think of it is
it is almost the one-way function
equivalent of this new branch of
cryptography called small box
cryptography
and
why is it i mean considering there's a
conjecture why is it of sub interest so
to speak is because
at the end of the day what we come up
with is something
that is almost a real aes and there is
no unspecified big components
and it basically explains existing uh
constructions and hopefully will guide
new designs
and we derive precise quantitative
bounds when where there's an explicit
dependence on the number of runs and the
results we get is strong but certainly
more conservative than some of the real
world choices anyway um so what do we
get when we apply the small box
cryptography framework to our spn
um so let me tell us let me tell you how
it works using the most aggressive big
to small conjecture we get the following
security that uh we get uh for an eight
bit s box we get security which is
epsilon equals two to the negative eight
r over three uh where r is the number of
rounds now plugging in some values we
get 10 to the negative eight or
basically one over 100 million security
when we use 10 rounds sort of what aes
does and if we increase it up to 24
rounds we get much better security
now the there are some what do we what
is this what is the setting
uh we prove it for random s boxes but
because the x boxes are so small we can
sort of hardwire it
and
we
have this constraint on the linear p box
uh basically it cannot have any zeros uh
the inputs matrix and its inverse have
no zeros
so what is this this is almost the real
aes and why is it of substance again is
because we get precise quantitative
round dependent security and there is
nothing unspecified here
now
yeah
is this like aligned with what we know
about aes in terms of the security that
we get
um yes i'll cover it in just a few
slides so what do we actually know in
traditional cryptography so what do we
actually know uh that's that's an
amazing segue into my next talk with
next part of the talk is how does the
small box thing that we we're throwing
it in how does it actually contrast with
something that we know traditional
krypton which we call it the big box
uh we typically have this hard object um
which is basically this box which is at
least security parameter big and it's
from a whole bunch of assumptions you
can have the big boxes uh or an
idealized model
and the issue is that it sort of does
not capture real-world symmetric crypto
because it it's often too coarse and
abstracts away the most interesting
parts i mean at least what we consider
the most interesting parts and it does
not really give you a picture about how
to build it from something really small
which is basically an 8-bit xbox
okay so what does traditional crypto or
big box crypto give us in terms of spn
analysis
so the idea is basically replace the
entire spn structure with one big
permutation pi
right and the thing is now it's no
longer spn
okay we have a solution let's just
rename it and we will get we call it the
key alternating cipher or kac
and typical security analysis is we
prove that the we prove the prp security
in the big box framework of a random
permutation model
but immediately we get that even one
round is enough that's a famous even
ivan mansour cipher
and which brings us to the question is
it enough to bring theory to practice
and the answer is that it does not
appear to be
right and why is that so basically if we
look at what we are selling on one hand
we have this spn which we analyze in
small box security we say it's two to
the negative eight r over three security
in our rounds
right
which is very precise clear but then on
the other hand i mean yes so they high
five they celebrate the practitioners
are really happy but on the other hand
you basically have something like the
evan munso cipher which is basically a
whole bunch of question marks because
you don't know what is the security in
terms of the number of runs and you also
don't really know how to instantiate the
spy so why is something like the spn
better choice choice of pi as opposed to
something else or
uh and any spn is never actually uh
ideal right because there's always this
huge gap between what is ideal and what
is real um and when we give it to the
practitioners there's a bit of a head
scratching
right so this is the state and what and
so basically we have these two framework
the small box and the brick box and the
goal is and basically what we get is
meaningful security in
um as a function of grounds
and we also get
nothing unspecified everything is
clearly specified but obviously there's
this big conjecture part so what is this
small box let's open it up slightly
so it's mixture of hardness
proofs and hardness conjectures so the
first step is traditional hard or
impressive reduced round proof which we
do it in the big box work and which is
conceptually odder than normal proofs we
use that's some kind of domain extension
and
on the other hand the second step is
hardness amplification step which is
possibly provable again we do it in the
big box world and what the idea is that
you will amplify the result
for multiple runs under the same runtime
of the adversary
and it could be unconditional with
independent keys uh the results of moral
at all um gives us that a little bit of
theory grounding to make this result
probable
so we have oh my animation is slightly
glitching the third step or the
conjecture part which appears to be a
really crazy assumption but it's almost
needed to make the it's
needed you need something crazy to make
it go through so that's the part the
convicted small conjecture and it's the
only conjecture part of the framework so
we use extensive theory we use extensive
proofs and then make this jump uh to
sell uh to actually get meaningful
results so what is the big to small
philosophy
we present natural construction that
makes sense for any n
we typically have t comma epsilon of n
security but only if n is some a log d
or something and clearly the proof
breaks down if n is too small but
there's no magic attack actually so just
the proof breaks through so we basically
say okay the conjecture the philosophy
is that epsilon f of n is still
meaningful and still great even for n is
equal to constant so the conjecture of
heuristics is basically this in a
uh in a distilled format is despite
supporting proof breaking down we get
still security even when n is constant
and
there are many options for this choice
of epsilon prime of n and epsilon of n
based on our definition of approximately
and a definition of constant the most
aggressive version would be something
like okay epsilon prime of n is epsilon
of n plus something that accounts for
the brute force attack so if an attacker
can uh run at time t what is the
security loss when we have brute force
now is this out
the hope is yes but we need to be
careful because it's not true always
where it falls for direct product where
uh in place of cascade so with the go if
we can do if we are given s of x one and
so on and so forth s of x r and the
security is t t comma two to the
negative r n over 2 but it is trivially
breakable if n is equal to constant
but we don't know any attack if we
cascade or resort uh where the operation
sort of destroys the individual
instances
so general attack on cascade might also
attack aes right because
aes is basically this cascading spn
structure over and over again
and interestingly what we can do is we
can take our
framework our recipe and follow the same
thing and we end up with uh an alpha and
a stream cipher or a prg which we can
independently prove securing with
something that's from the big box world
in the under the under the variant of
the lpn assumption there's no behind the
scenes there is no fudging of anything
there's no conjecture but it's something
that's direct so we basically have this
collision between big box and small box
which is interesting and clearly more
validation is needed
but
the the bigger question is why is this
better than just saying aes is secure
small box crypto has a really large
movable component in fact you should
wrap up okay yeah i'm almost done i'm
just going to the uh so what we get is
everything is precise and we get
quantitative bounds in a very systematic
way yes there is a conjecture which is
syntactically natural and we prove it
for any end so the big bigger bigger
picture almost done
we need theory of hardness from small
components conventional models or
assumptions
so the hope is we have this new thing
which is the big to small conjecture
which is sort of friendly to small box
cryptography we can think of it as
one-way function
so what is the new philosophy for design
we are stuck in the thing we need the
worm we don't know what to do so we go
to the big box world
we solve everything that's possible in
the big box world but then we come back
to the small box but we don't really
come back empty-handed we come back with
all the proofs that we have done in the
big box
and clearly a lot of work remains but
hopefully this
is the starting step to this unlocking
this whole world of research called the
small box crypto thank you for your time
okay thank you very much haris thank you
for those amazing uh animations
um
well slightly over time if somebody has
a brief question he can ask now when the
next speaker prepares so this is nikon
right
yep that's me
okay so you can share your screen
okay and now we're gonna hear about how
to get average case np homeless
all right hi everyone so i'll be
presenting average case hardness of np
and ph from worst case fine grained
assumptions
and this is drunk work with lija chen
and shiichi hirohara
so we're all familiar with the p versus
np question
but how does it relate to cryptography
so if p equals np
then there are fast algorithms for many
hard problems
but sadly it also means that there's no
cryptography
on the other hand if p does not equal np
then there are no worst case fast
algorithms for np-complete problems
but what does that say about
cryptography or even average case
hardness
it turns out that we don't really know
and it remains an open question
but to get a better understanding of
what possible worlds we could be living
in
empowerzo devise of five possible worlds
relating to the existence of algorithms
for hard problems and cryptography
for example if we look at the hardness
column here
these green implications upwards are
straightforward
if there is public key crypto then
one-way functions exist
and if one-way functions exist then np
is hard on average
and so on
but on the other hand
implications in the other direction are
unknown
and for example if we look at the second
yellow arrow
if this implication did hold
that would mean that np would be hard on
average if and only if p does not equal
np
and what this means is that the world's
heuristica in the second row here could
not exist
so each yellow arrow corresponds to
eliminating a possible world
and
identifying which world we live in is a
central question in complexity theory
and theoretical cryptography
but unfortunately
there are many barriers in the way of
proving these yellow arrows
and any proof of a yellow arrow here
has to simultaneously overcome all the
barriers in its way
okay let's give some quick complexity
background to define some notation
and we have also some new worlds like uh
yeah that's that's very true
definitely we'll we'll mainly deal with
your standards but yes there's
lots of wild worlds out there in crypto
so for some complexity background
we have p and np just defined in the
usual way
we also also use up standing for
unambiguous polynomial time
witnesses which is like np
okay
uh segments
and itp are defined as usual as classes
within the polynomial hierarchy
and which is also defined as usual but
these classes uh aren't true
much about it
so i'm going to define average here
to be the set of all
nikon
i think you have an internet problem
okay i think we lost him
let's give him a minute to
try to return
it's not going to okay i see him back
sorry
yeah you had some internet
issues
um so please uh
yeah so just re-share your screen
and maybe jump back like
seven seconds like okay yeah you define
pnnp
that's fine and yeah take it from here
sure so up stands for unambiguous pawn
on
its time
it's a stand defensive p except that all
when inputs are going to have at most
one witness
meaning that um
every yes instance it must have exactly
one witness which is different than np
but every no instance has zero witnesses
just like np
uh sigma 2p and pi2p are going to be
defined as usual as classes within the
polynomial hierarchy which is also
defined as usual
but if you haven't seen these complexity
classes before then then don't worry too
much about it but now let me define some
average case notions which are going to
be crucial for us
so i'm going to define average p
to be the set of all languages l
and distributions d
such that there's an algorithm solving l
always correctly but the expected
running time of the algorithm
when taking inputs according to
distribution d
is polynomial
and i want to emphasize that when i say
expected polynomial time here i mean the
expectation taking over inputs according
to distribution d and not internal
randomness
and that's what makes this an average
case notion
similarly we'll define distributional
curly c
to be the set of a length l and c
and distributions d that are polynomial
time stampable and this just allows us
to syntactically say that some class of
languages and reasonable distributions
have average case algorithms
recently hirohara had a breakthrough
work in giving evidence towards
eliminating heuristica the world where
np is hard on the worst case yet easy on
average
specifically
he showed that if this class up
has this worst case complexity
assumption that it can't be solved in
time 2 to the o of n over log n
then distributional np does not contain
an average p
or equivalently np is hard on average
he showed a similar result for the
polynomial hierarchy and also one for np
instead of up
except now this last consequence here
means that np can't be solved in average
case polynomial time where the run time
must also be able to be efficiently
estimated for all inputs without having
to run the algorithm itself
it turns out that if we look at this
first result for example
two of the three barriers from before
apply for this result but it was unknown
if the relativization barrier also have
to be overcome in proving this result
and one can ask you know can we do
better than this first result you know
can we use a weaker worst case
complexity assumption to give the same
consequence that np is hard on average
but it turns out that for this question
a new relativization barrier indeed does
come up
showing that it might be difficult to
directly improve these results
and one crucial thing to point out here
is that these results just fall short of
the exponential time hypothesis
as a quick reminder the exponential time
hypothesis says that three sat on m
variables requires two to the omega m
time
which is a much stronger assumption than
p design equal np
yet these worst case complexity
assumptions considered in the theorem
statements are stronger than eth and
indeed they're even stronger than the
strong exponential time hypothesis scth
and the reason why is just due to the
way three set instances are encoded as
binary strings
okay so this begs the question
what is the weakest
worst case complexity assumption
that implies non-trivial average case
hardness
our answer is that we can get
non-trivial average case hardness from
the exponential time hypothesis and even
in some sense much weaker worst case
assumptions
specifically
we show that if u p has a weaker worst
case complexity assumption that it can't
be solved in time two to the over root n
log n as opposed to two to the o of n
over log n
then non-deterministic linear time can't
be solved on average in quasi-linear
time this other n meaning n times poly
log n
we get a similar result for the
polynomial hierarchy but there's one
thing i want to especially emphasize
here
previously it was unknown even average
case hardness of sigma 3p implies
average case hardness of sigma 2p
but here we show that not only average
case hardness is sigma kt implies
average case hardness of sigma 2p but in
fact even worst case hardness of sigma
kp for any k implies average case
hardness or sigma 2p
and lastly with the exponential time
hypothesis directly we get n to the one
plus epsilon hardness
except that the runtimes also be able to
estimate it in time and to the one plus
epsilon
the main technical contribution that
enables these results to go through
and recognition be wrapping up
okay
so the main point is that what enables
these results are very efficient
pseudorandom generators
so our theorem is that from an average
case easiness assumption we get a prg
that has log m seed length
um that fools t time distinguishers
yet the prg is computable in t times
poly m time
which is very little overhead in the
case where t is very big like there's
only a poly m overhead in the between
the class of distinguishers of fools and
the run time itself
and this efficiency is what enables
these results
just to summarize and give some open
questions
you know we use metacomplexity just as
hirohara does and
this allows us to overcome the barriers
and perhaps fine-grained complexity is
the right lens to look at this through
and pseudorandomness is unsurprisingly a
very powerful tool
and for some open questions you know can
we do better than two to the o of root n
log n in this assumption is there any
barrier
and can we go from fine-grained average
case hardness perhaps all the way to
fine grained crypto
all right thanks so much that's all
okay thank you very much nikon that was
great
i think these are great progresses on
this question and we don't have time for
questions so we'll just move on to luan
will tell us if we are sitting close to
him or far away from him
okay
it's okay can you show your screen
can you see okay yeah great to run
okay
yeah thank you very much for the
introduction
um so yeah i will be talking about this
recent joint work with yahuwah leo and
chi pandeo um from ut austin and simon's
institute and as elon has
currently introduced our work will be
about beating classical impossibility of
position verification
so just to tell you the setting of the
work so what is the task of position
verification
um so just think of uh you have an
astronaut
and
he is going away for some uh space
exploration
task and you want to
verify that his position is indeed at
the correct position
so for this talk let's think about this
as approval who wants to prove his uh
position to
the verifier so here's a verifier so the
main thing or the main technique you can
do
is what is called distance funding which
is that um
if you send a message to the approver
and expect it to respond instantaneously
and if you time the uh
this response time then you will be able
to estimate the distance uh
in particular for example in this
example um
uh you will be certified that he is
within this circle um
from your location
so in order to get a better estimate
what you can do is to simply repeat this
process with
a bunch of other verifiers and then
triangulate the approval like so
unfortunately this very simple
technique or idea
um it's actually insecure if you
consider multiple adversaries that um
that are colluding and want to jointly
convince you that
they are in an incorrect position so in
this example
these two adversaries are able to
convince the prover that they're in the
middle but in reality both of them are
very far away from the middle
with the naive protocol that i just
described
so what is the state of the art for
position verification um so this task
was first formalized by chandran goyal
moriarty and ostrovsky in 2009
and there they also showed that
in general if you have a purely
classical protocol
then
a bunch of colluding adversaries can
always attack your protocol
um yeah and
at the same time they also um
give another classical protocol that is
secure against bond storage adversaries
in particular they assume some power
assumption
on the capabilities of the anniversary
and prior to our work all uh the other
position verification protocols um are
quantum
in particular um they
use quantum communication
um
and
one uh very important property that they
use
is the no cloning property of quantum
communication
and therefore this begs the question um
which is that can we still get around
the classical impossibility with only
classical communication and this brings
me to the um
our main result which is that we show
that assuming that learning with errors
which is
a widely used cryptographic assumption
is hard against
quantum computers
then we show how to get classically
verifiable position verification
against unentangled quantum adversaries
so what do i mean by classically
verifiable it means that
all of the verifiers only have classical
capabilities
in particular this also implies that um
the communication of the protocol is
purely classical
um so one actual question is can we do
better than what we achieve here
and we also prove that
for
a classically verifiable position
verification you will have to use the
quantum prover
in order to not hit the classical
impossibility
and at the same time we also show that
you have to assume some computational
assumptions in particular
we show that any such protocols implies
the proof of quantities
for a single proof
and the nice thing about our
construction is that it is actually very
simple
and a lot of the existing ideas from
quantum position verification
literature can be more or less naturally
ported over to our protocol without much
trouble and this is uh brings me to the
second part of our result which is that
we can strengthen our base protocol
with stronger security guarantees if we
assume a stronger hardness assumption
so in the first part
if we assume lwe is sub exponentially
hard then using some ideas from
the quantum position verification
literature we get um a protocol
that is provably secure against
adversaries with bonded entanglement or
if you know the entanglement bond a
priority
um
of course this is not very ideal but if
you want so if you want unbounded
entanglement then we can actually we
also show how to combine our protocol
with unrules protocol to get a protocol
that is secured back as on bonding and
handling but the security is only proven
in the quantum random oracle model which
is also a very standard uh
quantum cryptographic ideal model
so
finally we also show that for the
standard model construction so
everything except the last one
we also showed that if you ensure enough
entanglement then you can
of course that's
enough polynomial amount of entanglement
you can also attack our protocol
efficiently
so
it remains an open question whether you
can get a standard model
probably secure position verification
and this more or less matches the state
of art in the quantum position
verifications
in terms of
entanglement
in particular it is also not known
whether there is a standard model
entanglement unbounded entanglement
secure protocol
in a standard model
okay
so
instead of telling you how we achieve
this instead i want to motivate
why having classical communication
actually could matter uh for practical
purposes um beyond the theoretical
interest
and can i ask a question
yes
did you allow shared randomness like for
free and you only bound here the
entanglement
uh
yes uh anything classical share
randomness is allowed you can't share um
any polynomial or not sharing
okay thanks the only thing is um
entanglement that and this is similar to
what happens for quantum position
verifications as well
okay so going back to the practical
advantages of our protocol
so the main
disadvantage
which is like the dual advantage of
classical communication so the
disadvantage of quantum communication is
that in the context of position
verification
the only
the only model of
or the only means of communication that
makes sense is wireless communication or
free space communication because it
wouldn't make sense to have a position
verification practical with wire
communication
and
uh
one inherent property of wireless
communication is that its loss is very
high
and why is this a problem well actually
uh back in 2015 um
the offices have shown that a lot of non
quantum position verification protocols
break down if the
loss of the
communication is high and therefore it's
ongoing research to construct loss
tolerance position verification
protocols
and
as far as we are concerned there are
only two works that construct full loss
fully loss tolerant position
verifications
uh which means that
it will give you some meaningful
guarantee no matter how high the loss is
as long as bounded away from
from one
or noticeably bounded away from one
but unfortunately this uh the security
for these protocols are only proven
against unentangled adversaries
and
but if you look back at what happens for
classical communication well you can
just repeat the classical communication
at
no cost to the security and therefore a
corollary of our work is that we
actually get four loss tolerance even
against entangled adversaries which we
believe is not something that is known
before
um
yeah so there are also other practical
advantages like uh
if you are sending classical
communication you don't need a laser
whereas
for qkd people have been using a laser
to do uh free space qkd
and uh it is also easier for composition
so to conclude my talk um
so there are a few uh interesting open
questions in this area
one thing i will mention is that our
protocol requires some proverbs to have
some quantum memory and our security
proof relies on a notion of
computational accountability so one
quest one very nice question
is that whether we can remove quantum
memory from the prover
uh
uh
like because this seems possible um but
we don't know how so that concludes my
talk thank you very much
okay thank you very much that was really
cool
especially the lasers
um
yeah james you can go ahead and
show your screen
okay so james is gonna tell us how to
use circuits that always output zero
er the state is yours great thank you um
yes i'll be discussing this work um
in distinguishability obfuscation of
null quantum circuits and applications
and this is joint with julia malibolta
all right so first some a little bit of
background on classical obfuscation so
an office skater is a compiler that
takes a computer program p and outputs
an obfuscated program
and the point of the office gator is to
scramble the program
in order to hide its implementation
details while maintaining the
functionality okay
and so the security property at least
for this notion of indistinguishability
obfuscation says that for any two
functionally equivalent programs their
obfuscations should be computationally
indistinguishable and
this has been a really hot topic in
cryptography over over the last decade
um
probably just because it has so many
applications um it's been called the
central hub of cryptography it implies
you know a bunch of crazy things fully
homomorphic encryption functional
encryption
public key quantum money and the list
goes on and on
um and so there's been a lot of work in
you know the classical cryptography on
building stuff from io there's also been
a lot of work on building i o itself
okay and so after again you know decades
of work we have um
right now a nice construction from
well-understood assumptions that include
bi-linear maps so we also have a very
active line of research that's also
providing post-quantum candidates
that don't rely on bi-linear maps
so this is still an active area of
research
um
so this talk though is about the notion
of quantum obfuscation which
has been you know much less well studied
but it asks like us the simple extension
of this question the classical setting
right so if you have a quantum circuit
or you know a computer a quantum
computer program
um
you know can we also compile it with an
officiator into an obfuscated version
right and so
just to mention there's a few works that
have dealt with this notion of quantum
obfuscation a few on
you know defining things in the quantum
setting extending some classical
impossibilities to the quantum setting
but in terms of applications and
constructions much less is known than in
the classical setting so
in terms of applications other than i o
itself
i am pretty much only aware of this um
this work that shows that quantum i o
implies this notion of witness
encryption from qma which i'll actually
touch on a little bit later
um and in terms of constructions there's
a few there's a couple of works that
have studied uh you know what which
classes of quantum circuits can be
perfectly off these gates so these will
necessarily be for like pretty limited
circuit classes we can't really hope to
perfectly obfuscate um all quantum
circuits
um and there's another recent work
this recent work also shows that we can
do
quantum i o for um
for circuits that consist of only
clifford gates plus very few
non-clifford gates so actually like
logarithmically many non-clifford gates
so this gives and this is from classical
io so this gives a you know a set of
class of circuits that can be io'd but
it's um
quite limited
all right so
in particular this question
remains open um
is it possible to realize
indistinguishably obfuscation for
general quantum circuits and
by open i mean like we still don't even
know if any candidate constructions or
you know heuristic constructions um
you know in the classical setting we
i've we've known candidates for about a
decade now and the initial candidates
kind of sparked a huge line of research
on this question in the quantum setting
we don't even have yet a candidate for
for obfuscating all circuits okay
um
so so our work is um
basically attempts to address um both
aspects of quantum obfuscation so both
applications and um constructions so
i'll first um
present um our first result which is
which is our construction
so
um assuming the quantum hardness of
learning with errors a standard post
quantum hardness assumption along with
virtual black box obfuscation for
classical circuits
um we show that there exists an
obfuscator that operates on quantum
circuits okay
with correctness so it basically for
every quantum circuit it um it maintains
um functionality and i should mention
these are quantum circuits with
classical output so it maintains
functionality
um for security we ask for
um for any pair of quantum circuits q1
and q2 such that both q1 and q2 output
zero with overwhelming probability on
every input basically that they're both
null circuits
their obfuscations should be
computationally indistinguishable
okay so basically we're asking for
functionality preservation for all
circuits but security only for pairs of
null circuits and this is extending um
this classical notion of no i o that has
been studied before
okay
and yeah before moving on i should just
say a few words about this assumption so
we know actually that vv obfuscation is
impossible in general there exists like
contrived circuits that just can't be be
obfuscated
um but what you could do is say well you
know we we actually use the notion of
vbb to like to get our security proof to
work but you could just plug in an
indistinguishability obfuscator in place
of this vbb obfuscation in the actual
construction and still conjecture that
the um you know the resulting quantum
obfuscator is secure so that's kind of
similar to what you know people do with
hash functions the random oracle model
so you know it gives a heuristic
construction
we also show that we can replace this
assumption with a classical i o plus
something that we define called dual
mode classical verification of quantum
computation in the paper unfortunately
this is also only known heuristically at
the moment so
the takeaway right now is that what we
construct is a candidate or heuristic
construction of io for a large class of
circuits namely all um null circuits
okay
um
and then the next part of our our
results are on applications so you know
uh we construct this object and actually
our obfuscated circuit is can be
classically described
um and first we show that this still
implies witness encryption for qma
okay with the classical cipher text and
then we go on to show that this this
this um witness encryption primitive for
qma is actually very powerful and
implies a lot of things so
um for example this allows us to give
the first candidate construction of
non-interactive zero knowledge for qma
okay
which has not been known before
another example is we give the first so
attribute-based encryption is a is a
notion of fine-grained public encryption
that has been pretty well studied in the
classical setting and we give the first
construction for abe for um
quantum predicates for predicates and
bqpp okay
and i'll have to
refer you to the paper for all of these
like implications um i just want to
spend like a couple of minutes on this
actual construction of quantum nullio
which is actually pretty simple
so
we basically use two tools one is a two
message
blind classical verification of quantum
computation protocol cvqc
so this is between like a quantum prover
and a classical verifier it's just a two
message protocol where um you know the
verifier has a circuit queue they want
to evaluate it the preview has an input
um the preview provides a proof and then
the verifier outputs um q of x which is
equal to y okay so this is just a two
message classical communication cvqc
protocol
we need to assume that it satisfies both
blindness and soundness
and we can get this by just combining a
recent work on cbqc with a quantum fhe
scheme okay
and then we also need an obfuscator for
classical circuits but given these the
construction is
is quite simple
so to obfuscate a circuit queue
you run the verifier generation
algorithm to get public parameters
corresponding to q which is like the
message sent to the prover but then you
just simply classically obfuscate the
verifier's output circuit okay so
the obfuscation the quantum obfuscation
of q are these public parameters along
with a classical obfuscation of this
output
and then to evaluate you just produce
you run the perimeter to produce the
proof plug it into this classical
obfuscation to get the result line
um
so quickly why is this you know possibly
secure well what we can show is that if
q is a null circuit then this classical
oracle this obfuscation can basically be
replaced with the all zeros of oracle
and we can show that any adversary that
distinguishes these oracles even if they
even if they have superposition access
to these oracles can can be used to
break the soundness of cbqc so we can
safely replace this with the zeros
oracle and at this point we can hide q
we can argue that the public parameter
is high q due to the blindness of cbqc
and so this is established that this
entire obfuscation here
is you know basically hiding to you
okay
um
yeah so that's all i wanted to say about
the construction uh you can see the
paper for more details uh quickly
wrapping up with a couple open questions
suggested by this work uh one natural
one is you know can we extend our
construction to get io for all quantum
circuits not just null circuits
and if you try to directly extend our
approach you run into an issue which is
basically requiring that the underlying
underlying cbqc scheme that we use
satisf satisfy something called reusable
soundness and blindness meaning that
it's secure even if the approver can
query the verifier over and over again
it turns out that known cbqc protocols
as we show are actually not reusable and
we show attacks on them so this is a
nice open question as if we can come up
with such reusable cvqc schemes and
extend our approach to obfuscating all
quantum circuits
and then another one is just can we get
any you know or no io or even any of our
implications
from
just say i o for classical circuits so
can we remove the vbb assumption from
our proofs and
so that's all i wanted to say so thanks
for listening
okay thanks james thank you very much
if there's any questions people are all
welcome to ask
i'll just say in the meantime that so
you use vbb for this
verifier circuit right at the end
so it could be that you cannot can come
up with a protocol with well this video
verifier is like extremely simple so
maybe we
actually do have vb for
right yeah you're right if you look at
actually what that
verification algorithm is doing it is
pretty simple like the operations are
actually simple um
but
yeah it is it is unclear how to actually
uh you know um instantiate that from bbb
so we've looked into that a little bit
yeah
we do have ubb for like a lot of classes
of circuits rather simple and also maybe
this very fair like escapes the
impossibility results at least
so um
so like you do have a candidate okay
thanks james that was cool i think
obfuscation will be like
one of the main things in the next
10 years
20 years when it becomes like very
practical
um okay that's the end of our session
there's another session that started
like two minutes ago in bombie
you're all welcome to join
thank you so much and
see you in the other sessions
you